hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
june 7th lucky seven oh jesus
june 7th 2021 what's going on how
are you how's it going oh
happy birthday to me happy birthday to
me
it's coming up on thursday happy
birthday to me
i'll be 53.
um anyway sorry
can you tell i have a lot of [ __ ] to do
today you feel the frustration
too much [ __ ] just not enough time where
does the time go
um yeah anyway um
it's a gloomy june gloom morning out
here out here in los
angeles uh just drop my beautiful
daughter off
at school it's funny today she didn't
want to listen to any music did i tell
you
the other day we were going to school
driving to school
and i go what do you want to listen to
and she goes black and black
because she doesn't know i keep saying
it's back in black and now she knows
that but now she thinks it's funny to
say it the wrong way
so she goes black and black and i go all
right so i put it on
and then she goes louder
raising her right raising her right and
now i got to listen to all this country
music that i'm into
she likes uh waylon and willie um
that's what you do you just they like
their songs and then you just introduce
a new one the first one like i don't
know what this is and then they know a
few words then they like it
and then then they're into it and then
they request it and then you move on to
the next thing
so it's pretty cool because me and my
wife listen to like really different
compared to each other music you know
what i mean
um so i think she'll have a nice
a wide variety of music that she likes
which is really cool
so anyway uh yesterday you know the
whole family we went over to this uh
amazing a buddy of ours it was
his their son's uh second birthday
so um we went over there for this big
near the bouncy house and all that stuff
and just all of this sugar
stuff so the kids were just going
nuts having a good time going down
slides and
climbing all over them it's really it's
really ridiculous
the level that a kid party is now you
know it used to just be you know you got
fake guns and a cowboy hat and then
everybody went outside and you reenacted
the genocide that started this country i
mean that's what you did
you know we weren't like these spoiled
kids with their big bouncy [ __ ]
houses
okay
as kids we we we understood
how this country came about it wasn't
all [ __ ] cake pops
and [ __ ] puffy [ __ ] to [ __ ] slide
into
uh no i'm kidding uh ended up being
great and there was uh
some people there making burgers you
know those ones that i've been trying to
figure out how to make the really flat
ones
that are crispy but juicy on the inside
so uh the guy running the grill
the flat top grill broke it down for me
so i'm gonna try it out
and uh you know just had a great time
showing off my kids or every kid there
was cool
just very rare at a kid party there's
usually
some kid with shitty parents or parents
that are going through something and the
kid's just
acting out and you have to sit there be
and and just be
an adult and be like okay that's a kid i
can't get mad at the kid i got to keep
my eye on him
you know i got to see where he's at and
where my kids at you know the hell with
these other kids those aren't my kids
no i'm kidding i actually look out for
the other kids too um
but you got to keep your eye on him
what's he going to do
what is this little future banker future
politician
future uh uh high level of executive at
some [ __ ]
corporation what is this little [ __ ]
future suit wearing [ __ ]
gonna do next usually you have to worry
about that but not at this party
everybody's kids
were cool you know
you know i don't know i don't know i
don't know if it's just the time i grew
up in or that i had [ __ ] orange hair
but i just like i just sit there and
watch my daughter going all right
where's the bully it's coming i know
it's coming it always comes
and i was just sitting there watching
her for like 20 minutes before i
realized that i was like a [ __ ]
psychopath going like she's playing with
the kids the kids are fine everything's
fine
and i literally said to my wife i go i
can like this is cool right she goes
yeah relax she finds us
all right you know so i just walked over
to the fence and stared off into the
woods
like a crazy person um
but anyway um we had a great time and
the day before we went to try and find
a gift for this little boy and uh
we'd gone out to lunch me and my lovely
wife and we just wandered into this
little kid clothing store and they had
these toys there
and i'm noticing the toys are starting
to come back around these little
boutique stores they have like
you know they have these cars that are
like made out of wood
and the wheels are made out of rubber
and [ __ ] like that it's actually going
back to like
you know i when i when i was a kid that
was just ending
you know and i remember my dad would
look like christ these these are just
cheap pieces of [ __ ]
you know cause the tires would be all
plastic
and uh i remember when the cars
when uh i don't know by like the late
70s i remember we
needed a new car and my dad just
complained at this dashboard chris said
just you know when i was a kid billy
i'll tell you this was all
wood it was gorgeous you know what i
mean it was
you just had chrome as far as the eye
could see
guys look at this she could [ __ ] put
your fist through it
i mean he wasn't wrong
so um i don't know it's a weird balance
but you're like well you know and then
if you start making wood cars for all of
these kids
you know they're you're going to run out
of trees unless you replant them
you know which is which what brings back
due to why there's pandemics
why nature tries to thin the herd
and you know we got to fight her back
what are we going to just roll over and
let her kill us
um you know it's a it's a balance
you try to find the balance so anyways i
found this really cool they
was basically you know that great
lincoln continental the uh 60 to like 67
one with the suicide doors
they had one in all white with like this
fender blue
like that surfer blue that they have on
fender guitars
top on it with rubber wheels the thing
was the [ __ ] i was looking at like i
want that
um so we ended up getting them that so
uh you know figure little boy that's
what they like greatness is not what
they're into i don't know
uh it was funny because later on that
night we came back
and uh because at the end of the party
uh my buddy was like hey man he goes i
got that mayweather logan paul
fight he goes do you want us do you want
to watch it and i
and i laugh i go no and he laughed he's
like
you know whatever um it's like do i want
to watch that it's like do you want to
watch me
go up against somebody who flew the
space shuttle to see who's the better
[ __ ] pilot
um do you want to watch the guy who
flies the space shuttle act like
he can't fly as well as i can do
do you really want to sit and pay and
watch that but
uh but whatever me my wife hadn't had a
night out and uh
i got some family in town so he invited
us all over i said yeah [ __ ] it let's do
it so we went over there and
oh my god jesus christ all i can say
about that fight was i remember a long
time ago um
when i was just starting out as a
comedian and i went into
um i went into the comedy connection
because it was a famous comic that was
in town and i wanted to see him
and he improved a lot of his [ __ ] right
and i wanted to see what that was like
because i was so
afraid to improvise and [ __ ] and i went
in there
and it was like deathly deathly quiet in
there
like it was almost like
i walked in thinking there was nobody on
stage
and uh the guy was on stage and he was
just
[ __ ] eating his balls
like i don't even know what i don't even
know what to tell you all right
and he got off stage it was [ __ ]
brutal it was one of the worst bombs i
ever saw and i just remember the crowd
was walking out
just like like it was a funeral and i
just remember this boston chick walking
out
and she just goes that was the biggest
[ __ ] waste of money
and my literally my heart like sunk and
i was like oh my god
it put the fear of god in me i go i hope
nobody
ever says that about a show that i did
of course that happened but i just i
never forgot that and that's what i
thought after i watched that thing last
night i swear to god the only reason why
i didn't fall asleep was because i you
know you'd be polite at somebody's house
but like somewhere in the fifth round
when i realized he was just gonna carry
him for the whole [ __ ] fight
i just kind of put my head back and
closed my eyes then i was just like
don't do it don't do it don't do it
i'm up i'm up i'm up um
yeah so you know what are you gonna do
but i mean
you can't be upset if you ordered it i
mean the fact that muhammad ali didn't
knock out lal alzado
all those years ago i mean you know what
this is
okay when the professional
is fighting the person that's signing
his check
you got to know that uh
that uh that something is up so um
anyway uh moving on here
holy [ __ ] um
yeah that was just i don't even know
what that was that was just
a [ __ ] snoozefest um
let's speaking of snoozefest
jesus [ __ ] christ the winnipeg
jets what are you doing to me
can you win a [ __ ] game my god
i can't even imagine how many [ __ ]
canadian fans are tuning into this
podcast right now
just loving it probably ironed your
little pocket square
i love that they say that they wear
pocket squares you know like they
actually have class up there they don't
they're animals and the real french
people in france reject you
and they think you talk funny um
winnipeg jets winnipeg how about losing
jesus christ
am i right folks that was the biggest
[ __ ] waste of money
uh montreal canadians just [ __ ]
taking it to the winnipeg jets
um i don't know how good the winnipeg
jets are
but dare i say you know this canadian
team
that was described as pesky
maybe is a little bit better than people
think
um all right now as boring as that
series is
and as habs fans you got to be thinking
okay if we sweep these guys and just
watch the bruins and the islanders beat
the [ __ ] out of each other we have a
great chance
at making the final or is it the finals
i know i heard ray bork say the finals
so i'll say the finals
um yeah it's getting
very [ __ ] interesting if you're a
montreal canadian fan
uh bruins versus islanders just been a
[ __ ]
great great series and
um bruins looking to go up three to one
in game four islanders coming out
like with a sense of urgency
they jumped on us from the beginning of
the game and
um i just you know i just
it was one of those games like you ever
know just three minutes into the game
you're like we're not winning this game
we're not winning this game where we
have we have about another five minutes
to [ __ ] turn this around or this [ __ ]
is over
and even though it wasn't like you know
this wide
uh we were actually winning the game one
to nothing
um i believe all the games kind of run
together after a while
um but i got to give a tip of a cap to
uh hopefully say his name right matthew
uh brazil brazil
it's weird it's z-a-l but it's zil
brazil
um anytime you can get a lady bing
candidate to spear you in the nuts you
know you're doing your job
he's basically their uh
their uh marshawn you know which of
course they're gonna love him and then
say that marshawn is a [ __ ]
dirty piece of [ __ ] and they're
literally the exact same player the guy
that goes up
out there and stirs it up i would
absolutely
love that guy if he played on my team um
but i would never say that he's dirty
he's just he's a [ __ ] it's there's
nothing
you got to have those guys out there
just going out there irritating the [ __ ]
out he got david crazy to go to the
[ __ ] box i mean that's amazing that
never happens
um and he 100 deserved to be speared in
the balls
and i love that he then rolled around in
the ice like a [ __ ] soccer player
and then like two seconds later he's on
the power play flying down the [ __ ]
ice
[Laughter]
[Music]
but it was a great great game it's a
great series
and um and
i gotta tell you uh the islanders of
bruins better better make quick
work of one another if they're gonna
have a shot against the canadians
because they're gonna be
nice and rested um
nice and rested uh they look and all of
a sudden
this is what i love about the playoffs
the canadians it's like hey [ __ ] guys
look they're gonna lose the [ __ ]
toronto blah blah and all of a sudden
like a weak lady like these guys might
go to the finals
who knows who the [ __ ] knows
um so we shall see i think a bruins
canadian
uh easter concert uh conference final
obviously would be [ __ ] amazing
um and i would say that's a like like i
feel i feel we're
50 50 with the islanders 50 50 with
canadians
could win could lose and then i feel
like
you know the avalanche and uh
i don't know why i don't know why i
don't watch much of the vegas knights
but i just feel like that they
it's definitely the the western
conference's cup to lose
um whatever i got two [ __ ] kids four
and one what do you want from me
i'm doing the best i can here um
all right plowing ahead here
uh i just wrote i wrote something down i
don't even know what the [ __ ] this means
kid on the scooter oh yeah oh
[ __ ] so last night we were
driving over to watch that [ __ ]
snooze fest
um
and i'm driving down the street and this
[ __ ] kid you know they're unlike
those you know those those
scooters that the kids leave laying
around all over the place and they just
walk up like hey man
here's my [ __ ] credit card and then
they just like or their phone they touch
it with their phone and then they get on
and it powers up like something on star
trek
um they
anyways this guy and this woman get on
two different scooters and they're
riding and this kid without looking just
goes right out into the street in front
of me and i beeped at him
and he turns around gives me this
[ __ ] dirty look like i'm the [ __ ]
he turns around looks at me and then i
wave him to go i'm just beeping like
buddy
you're gonna get yourself killed he
gives me a [ __ ] dirty look
and then as he goes across the street
he [ __ ] drops his short exposes his
ass and slaps his own ass and pulls
his [ __ ] shorts up and i'm like the
[ __ ] was that
so i said i'm like what the [ __ ] does
that mean
i don't know kiss my ass i don't know
right
so anyway i'm like all right that was
weird and then we just drive off and i
forget what the [ __ ] we were laughing
we're just having a good time which is
why i wanted to go out last night so
we're having a good time and all of that
[ __ ]
so then um
we come back and once again we stop at
that light
uh at the intersection and i thought of
that kid again
no i know we got that intersection there
was somebody like kick and like ran
across the street and then kick
something some object and like sort of
talk to walked around what the [ __ ] is
that guy doing
then i was just like why did that kid
slap himself on the ass again i didn't
[ __ ] understand
and and then my wife i don't know she
just like
sided with the guy on the scooter
she goes i don't know probably to bug
you i mean he's still living in your
head
that's what she said oh my god i got so
[ __ ]
pissed so
[ __ ] first of all that she used that
hacky [ __ ] twitter speak
and then it's just like
you know that happened like three hours
ago i never brought it up again
and then we stopped at the same light
more crazy [ __ ] happened
and i'm kind of like what's with this
area
and then as always what your wife does
what do they do they always side with
the other [ __ ] person i just for the
for the i just don't understand it
i'm gonna [ __ ] start doing that i'm
gonna start doing that to her just for
my own
[ __ ] amusement the next time she
comes home and she's bitching about some
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and that's the key some [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know i went to the store and this
woman's just like you know
following me around going can i help you
can i help you and i'd be like well you
know were you acting shady
you know obviously that's because that
would be racial that still would be
funny i got to pick
so i can't do it in that situation i
still have to be like you know white
people
um let me see let me pick a better
example
i don't know maybe if one of her
girlfriends is [ __ ] or whatever
and i'll just see like well you know how
was your tone when you were talking to
her were you being like
were you in a bad mood
and at first she'll look at me weird and
then all i need to do is follow it up
again
where i make it her [ __ ] fault just
to say
i don't underst ladies can you [ __ ]
please explain to me
what that is is that just the resentment
of living with somebody after a while
that you just [ __ ] so don't you still
love him but you don't like him anymore
so then you just
you know all you can see is that they're
an [ __ ] that you live with so
anytime they come home bitching about
somebody else being an [ __ ] to them
secretly you're actually excited
is that what it is and then you never
see that you never you never stop to
think that
the guy you're with also lives with you
so maybe you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] too
but you're such a manipulative person
that he has to [ __ ] play by the rules
of your emotions
and still support you is that what it is
oh man that [ __ ] annoyed me you know
what annoys me even more about that [ __ ]
is it like [ __ ] happens all the time
and i call her out on it and then in the
end
she acts like then then they act like
the victim
so like this is how you feel about me
it's just like all right whatever
there's there's no winning this is there
there's no winningness okay
okay he's living in my head there you go
and that person last
week uh yes they were right and i was
wrong and the person that we yeah
everybody's [ __ ] right and i'm the
douche all right i get it i see how this
game is [ __ ] rigged
um and then what happens is then you
just give in
you give in you just go like okay fine
and then you get quiet
you're not mad you don't yell you just
go okay fine
and then they try to start conversations
you just kind of oh you know hey
whatever
and then they realize that you've had
enough
of their [ __ ] and then what do they
do
they start acting nice they start acting
the way they should be acted which is
nice
right that's how they start [ __ ]
acting and then what happens
then what happens right a couple days
goes by
and you're right back to where you were
again
i still love my wife i still think she's
[ __ ] the [ __ ] and all of that but
that is the [ __ ] right there
i'm telling you that as men we need to
learn there's nothing out there that
teaches you
how to [ __ ] navigate that women
there's this [ __ ] a whole
library of [ __ ] books on how to break
down
our [ __ ] game plan so they can get a
victory and there's just nothing out
there for us
so i'm just gonna try this [ __ ] and just
be like
uh i can't do it to her because then i
be then i'm doing the same thing
i just have to learn in those situations
to just accept the fact that she's
always gonna take the other person's
side
ah [ __ ] what are you gonna do
buddy i'm literally exhausted just
trying to make that funny
um but anyways i will tell you this
early in the day i was looking at it
going look at these two [ __ ]
beautiful kids she gave me so i guess
that's the trade-off maybe it's just the
balance of life maybe it isn't a [ __ ]
a [ __ ] you know
i love it that she gave me i love that
she gets all the [ __ ] credit you know
what i mean like i'm not part of that
mix
you know what i mean it just it just it
never
it never comes around you just have to
understand
that when you're a guy in a relationship
you're the toronto
toronto maple leafs right
[Laughter]
and she's every other franchise um all
right sorry
all right how about those brooklyn nets
huh jesus christ i mean
this is just the feel-good story of the
summer i just watching these these
[ __ ] kids
uh somehow come together just to find
the odds and just
who would have ever thought that if you
know you put uh
kevin durant [ __ ] uh oh speaking of
which the other guy there used to be on
the celtics
um you see him stomp on the logo
walked out and uh that kid threw the
water bottle
and of course they're gonna then me
immediately cue the eclipse of
bussing in boston from 50 years ago it's
like you also stepped on the logo
you know we also gave up
a great part of our team to get you
to come play for us and
you weren't a leader and you were a
problem and you were a [ __ ] head case
there is also that
and we're still kind of digging out of
that [ __ ] hole
that crater um there is also that
with obviously the obvious boston racism
and all of that [ __ ] but jesus christ
um anyway i'm just glad that he you know
he found a home with some other knock
around kids
you know that they can all try to come
together and
just defy the odds um
shout out to the los angeles lakers i
feel bad for those poor guys
you know what i mean just you know
i i just love a feel-good underdog story
and i just hate when injury
you know just casts a a a dice like that
you know it's just
really difficult to watch um i'm i'm
[ __ ] with you i don't want to see
anybody get hurt ever but like
at least one of the pylon teams was
derailed
this guy had 18 assists can you believe
it i absolutely can believe it
all right let's do uh let's do a little
uh advertising little ever twos in here
um this podcast might be a little bit
short because i have to do
a uh little phone here or i could do pit
pause do the phone and come back real
quick
maybe i'll do that all right look who it
is everybody
oh uh look at that pylon team doo doo
doo doo me undies be undies everybody is
a meme
beating the [ __ ] out of the rest of the
league
ah nothing rhymes with league i don't
know what that me undies everybody
summer is coming in hot
literally but with me undies breathable
and soft as heck fabrics you can soak up
the sun and feel cool for the summer
with a mix of classic colors and
adventurous prints perfect for summer
express yourself in your own unique way
hey top 10 ways to know that you have a
pylon championship team
uh they win the championship and later
on all of those hall of famers
none of them go into the hall wearing
your team's jersey
uh with a mix of classic colors and
adventurous prints perfect for the
summer express yourself in your own
unique way
because meundies believes that comfort
is about more than what's touching your
skin
it's about feeling comfortable in your
skin designed to be the softest thing
you've ever worn the undies are
energized by creatively
creativity and made for self-expression
available in sizes from
xs to 4x extra small to 4xl me undies
has countless styles
and prints to choose from so your buns
can have more fun
in the sun uh not in the sun they'll be
covered up with me on these beyondies
covering your [ __ ] cheeks do
do do do me undies be undies the purvy
ties to take a sneak
he looks up your shorts but they're nice
and tight
he's 20 years older and that ain't right
put on your pants and run away
from that [ __ ] weird guy over there
me undies has a great offer for my
listeners for any first-time purchasers
you get 15
off and free shipping that's what that
fight should have been last night free
me undies also has their problem-free
philosophy
uh if you're not satisfied with any
product for any reason they'll refund
or exchange it no caveats no question to
get your 15
off to get your 15 off your first order
and free shipping go to meundies.com
that's meundies.com for 15 off your
first order
and free shipping all right
okay let's get into the questions here
for the week um all right pride month
thank you dear billy boston baked bean
town balls um you know what i got to
tell you something about that baked bean
[ __ ] in boston
i lived there for 27 years i never had
baked beans i never
saw them i mean they were at the grocery
store you could buy baked beans but you
could do that in any [ __ ]
grocery store out there uh
uh well how do you let's find out the
history of that because i know there
wasn't really good farmland
which is why you have all those stone
walls throughout new england as they dug
up all of those [ __ ] stones
and they weren't really marking their
property as much as they were [ __ ]
trying to get rid of the goddamn things
um so they could what plant some beans
history of boston
baked beans i spelt history wrong
history uh
okay boston baked beans are a variety of
baked beans sweetened with molasses
and flavored with salt pork or bacon i
bet if they're actually made from
scratch they got to be delicious because
i
[ __ ] hate those things um history
native americans oh jesus
hey teach us how to make them their
beans thank you fella
now you're no more all right native
americans had made cornbread
and baked beans the pilgrims at plymouth
colony
learned these recipes in the early 1620s
and likely added barley to the cornmeal
to invent the new england brown bread
the triangular trade of slaves in the
18th century helped to make
boston an export of rum which is the
product
now how didn't that survive with all the
drunks in boston
rum is [ __ ] evil dude rum is like
j it's like gin is the worst and then
rum
uh which is produced by the distillation
of fermented molasses
at that time molasses was added to the
local baked bean recipes creating boston
baked beans
in colonial new england but where did
the beans come from baked beans were
traditionally cooked on saturdays and
left in a brick oven overnight on
sundays the beans were still hot
allowing people to indulge in a hot meal
and still come comply with
sabbath restrictions uh
brown bread and baked beans along with
frankfurters
continue to be a popular saturday night
staple throughout the region
no they don't no it doesn't
nobody on a saturday night in new
england is having brown bed with baked
beans and frankfurters
jesus christ boston is referred to as
beantown in reference to the popular
dish
from 1883 to 1906 the national league
baseball team in boston
was known as the boston bean eaters
the boston bean eaters this is how you
go down
oh wow that's what the original braves
were named
who knew that the atlanta braves that's
what it took me to
atlanta braves 66 to pro okay
1871 to 1875 boston red stockings then
they were the boston redcaps from 76 to
82.
then they were boston bean eaters from
83 to 1906 then they were the boston
doves we're here to make peace from 1907
to 1910
then they went the other way the boston
rustlers 1911
then they were the boston braves from
1912 to 1935 and who ended his career
with them
babe ruth uh then they were the boston
bees
from 1936 to 1940
then they were the boston braves from 41
to 52. what the [ __ ] was going on with
them
then 50 they moved to milwaukee 53 53-65
hank aaron boston braves and then 66 to
present the atlanta braves
well they have to have the record for
having the most names red stockings red
caps
bean eaters doves wrestlers braves
then bees then back to braves
move to milwaukee and then to atlanta
wow oh hey by the way shout out to gavin
macleod rest in peace man
there was a couple of big actors from
when i was
a kid that just did such amazing work
gavin mccloud
kelly's heroes um
marry tyler moore and then he got his
own show with the love boat i remember
seeing him he's played a uh
a gangster in peter gunn just an amazing
like
a guy could play everything from a
gangster all the way to a network show
about a cruise ship captain
um you know i don't know i don't know
what was in the water over there at the
mary tyler moore show but there's so
many people that lived into their 90s
it's kind of amazing
um let me see something here
trying to look up his imdb
oh and also obviously shout out to
charles grodin rest
in peace who is just one of the greatest
comedic actors of all time
and the fact that there's people to this
day
who's he was so in character they think
that he was actually that guy when he
used to do the talk shows
and he would come out and he would like
be an [ __ ] to johnny carson first of
all the balls that that took
because if you actually pissed him off
he was the only game in town and you you
would be
finished and if people in the industry
knew that johnny didn't like you then
they wouldn't put you in a movie because
you're not going to be able to promote
it on that show
he was the only game in town
and also when he hosted snl he played
this whole thing that you know
sorry if i stink tonight i didn't really
rehearse because i'm you know i'm in new
york i got to go shopping with my
celebrity money
and he never he never like let people in
on it
it was really like some andy kaufman
level [ __ ] like i remember seeing a clip
of it and it was in the middle of the
sketch
john belushi just just bails he's
dressed as like in the bee
outfit just going you know what man you
just been a jerk all week you know you
didn't show up for rehearsals or
whatever and then he's like oh what i
had a guy to go shop
they had like an argument in the middle
of it and people thought it was real
they were so like
in character look it up if you can find
it and there's still there's there's
places out there where they go
um where they'll they'll talk about you
know the worst hosts in snl history and
they always throw him in there thinking
that it was actually a real thing
but um his work on all of those shows
and then of course midnight run
him with robert de niro is one of my
favorite comedic combinations
of all time they just uh i have to go
back and watch that
um just an amazing
amazing movie oh and another guy
from that that movie uh
is it jaffet koto is that how you say
his name my favorite movie his was blue
collar
um i might go watch that again
i'm having a blast watching all these
[ __ ] old 70s movies like i watched
another clint i'm on this clint eastwood
run
so i watched um every which way but
loose
and now i've just started last night uh
any which way you can
his orangutan movies and uh
i gotta tell you something every which
way but loose
is the saddest character clint eastwood
ever played
he was a cowboy went in i don't i can't
remember if i talked about this last
thursday but like
he goes into some like country bar honky
tonk whatever they call him
and uh he falls in love with the singer
on stage who's just passing through town
and her deal is she's just a chick on
the road
she sings her song she finds a cute guy
she bangs him
and leaves him but he falls in love with
her and when she leaves town he tries to
find her
and you just think in the end like he's
gonna get her
he's gonna get her back spoiler alert
spoiler alert coming up i'm gonna say
what happens all right so cover your
[ __ ] ears
it just doesn't work out he's just this
he's just a sad sad guy
that fell in love with this fast woman
you know who just wasn't
you know didn't want to be in a
relationship
um at the end it's just him
in a [ __ ] ape um
anyway let's get back to the questions
here
let's get back to the questions here all
right um
dear billy boston bake bean town balls
all right so now you know the deal we
uh native americans taught us some [ __ ]
with the beans we we
judged them up a little bit and uh and
then you got it and evidently uh
you know i can't wait uh when i go back
to boston in august
you know i got a gig bag really
connecticut i'm gonna go back there you
know
uh and i'm gonna on saturday night if i
have a show afterwards i'm gonna eat
some boston baked beans with uh
some cornbread and uh frankfurter
uh jesus with a [ __ ] hat with a belt
buckle on it all right since it's lgbt
pride month lesbian gay bi
translucent uh i just want to say
thank you for being an ally oh jesus
even if you are a straight cis freckled
ginger [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] does sis mean
i'm sick of all these [ __ ] words i
need to know what the [ __ ] these things
mean
sis
sistine chapel
oh jesus and of course it's not gonna
denoting or relating to a molecular
structure in which two particular atoms
are groups of the same given plane in
the molecule what
cis i gotta look up cisgender
okay cisgender denoting or relating to a
person whose sense of personality
identity and gender corresponds with
their birth sex
oh all right
and why did it sound like it why does it
always sound like an insult
you're a man who relates to being a man
man
look at you you're a woman and you love
it
um uh yeah yeah kind
comfortable of who i am uh even if you
are a straight cis freckled ginger [ __ ]
all right there we go
uh it's always great to hear from you as
an ally without being
all sjw about it what does that mean
single jewish
whitey say
jerk which ah
right okay i'm gonna look up all these
[ __ ] words for all you other [ __ ]
out there sjw
definition
the [ __ ] is with my internet today oh i
know why i'm on the wrong one here
i'm on the wrong one and now it says you
are not connected to the internet and
then i got to hit refresh
then i have to refresh again and i got
to hit refresh again
and then this is where the old me used
to get pissed and the old me would get
oh you [ __ ] i'm starting to get
pissed i'm not going to let you
come on you [ __ ]
i guess i'm never going to know here
well you know what you don't need to
know everything in life all right i'll
just okay well i'm glad i'm not all
sjw about it sisters without voices
um the cancel mob obviously knows
nothing about you so [ __ ]
them it's not a mob it's a small group
of people it's not even a mop
thanks again and happy pride month don't
get a sunburn you fragile
skinny pasty [ __ ] go [ __ ] yourself my
voice just cracked a cut
you hurt my feelings man
don't get a sunburn you fragile skinny
pasty [ __ ]
go [ __ ] yourself all right there you go
see there's a gay dude you can hang out
with a gay woman you can hang out with
that person
you know
that's how you're gonna come at me i'm
really i'm feeling the love i'm feeling
feeling the respect you know what's
[ __ ] hilarious
is a few weeks ago when i was really
like got down to
the last layer of who the [ __ ] i am and
really
figured myself out to the point it so
blew my mind that i sideswiped a [ __ ]
mail truck and to have to go get my car
fixed
i was going like five miles an hour
those stupid bumpers stick out just a
little bit those honey baked hams that
they have on this side
and they just went right down the side
of my car and i was like oh god
oh god of the body shop yeah you took
out the whole side of your car
everything needs to be replaced um
anyway uh yeah just sort of discovered
something that i didn't even really kind
of like
understand about myself and what is so
[ __ ] ironic is i went out to do
stand-up
that night and i was so [ __ ] up in the
head i messed up my car
and i also [ __ ] didn't even feel like
doing stand-up right
so what's crazy about life is like god
you know i got to block this [ __ ] out of
my head so i can just go up the stage be
funny or not be too dark and go up there
and bum everybody else out right
and luck would have it i walk in and the
comic on stage
is literally joking about the [ __ ]
thing
that i was thinking about
this [ __ ] [ __ ] that happened to me
when i was a kid right
and um she was making fun of people that
you know that were in my position
and what cracked me up was i was just it
actually took me out of it because i was
like wait a minute
this is the place where i'm supposed to
get offended
to be like hey just to let you know i
was in therapy today
huh and i didn't
i didn't think that at all
i actually got a kick out of it and then
i thought well maybe if some more
traumatic [ __ ] happened to you you'd be
funnier that's all i thought i didn't
[ __ ] think
i'm gonna record this and post it and
try and ruin this person's [ __ ]
career
why because i'm an adult because i know
i'm at a comedy show and i know that she
was just [ __ ] around
all right um so anyways all right well
thank you
thank you to the person who just wrote
in i know that most people who listen to
this [ __ ] part
i know that most people in general
understand
and go to a comedy show and understand
all of this [ __ ] and it's just really
just you know lazy journalism and all of
that that you know you could be a
corporation and literally be polluting
the ocean while you align yourself with
gandhi
in your advertising and you don't get
called out but you know if you go up and
you do some [ __ ] joke i use a word
then all of a sudden people try and take
your career away
uh which is just yeah is
[ __ ] ridiculous i feel like this
whole
movement should the whole woke thing
should be a look inward
not walking around trying to point at
other people so you can get the stink
off of yourself
um that's all it is that's why
white women now call other white women
karen's
that's why hipsters called other
hipsters cara hipsters
they're just trying to get it off of
them uh
rather than actually doing the work but
that's not what happens people
just say i'm woke i'm a woke warrior
whatever the [ __ ] they're saying it's
just like no you're just as [ __ ] up as
everybody else you're not
as [ __ ] up as somebody in the clan but
does that mean you're a good person
because you're not in the clan like
that's your [ __ ] benchmark
all right i'm gonna go off on a [ __ ]
rant here let's let's let's spin it back
around to where the [ __ ] i'm supposed to
be talking about here all right
late 60s movie billy bastard uh have you
re-watched point
blank with lee marvin lately no i don't
think i've ever seen it
i've i've never seen it and only saw the
poster i'm 26
so i have some catching up to do i
remember you saying how much you love
him so
i've been re-watching a lot of his
movies he's [ __ ] amazing yeah
and just his voice and he was the real
deal too i mean that guy fought in world
war ii or korea one of those [ __ ]
wars and just
this whole platoon died except for him
and two other guys
uh acting is acting but there's
something about lines being delivered
from a guy who actually lived it yeah
i think comedy is probably the same way
experience helps the details
uh and the average viewer can see
through the [ __ ]
uh that's also though what is amazing
about actors who haven't lived it
you know anybody can kind of play them
itself which is why
a lot of times you'll see like uh you
know
a football player play a football player
in a movie and they're like that guy was
good
it's like true acting is it's that the
person's 180 degrees
you know different than who you are and
you pull it off
the accent the whole [ __ ] thing is is
um
and that seems to not get any respect
anyway p.s never knew who angie
dickinson was
what a fox go [ __ ] yourself angie
dickinson hang on a second let me look
that one angie
dickinson
uh images that's not the chick from
murder she wrote is it
oh no oh jesus yeah she is beautiful
um all right what was the other thing i
was looking up
the other thing because my got my
internet back sjw
that's [ __ ] hilarious it says i just
saw a picture
because i was on images it said where
did the term sjw come from
and it shows a white woman with glasses
in her eyes
wide open yelling at what i believe is a
white dude with a neck tattoo
oh social justice warrior
oh my god that is just such a [ __ ]
it's so
i almost said gay and then you get in
trouble for it's so douchey
i guess that's why you can't say gay
right because that you're saying that
gay people are douchey
uh but gay also used to mean happy i
mean words evolve
man [ __ ] it with you um
all right the fall guy
are you going to talk about lee majors
another one of my favorites growing up
the fall guy hey bill been reading about
evil leaders in history lately oh jesus
it's not the tv show this is the person
they put the blame on
uh one thing i found after deeper dives
is that there's always a group behind
the guy
that never gets any attention absolutely
whether it's all oligarchs rich people
in charge
money people banking groups and
religious groups which i found almost
always is backed by
the former two it seems like a huge
issue when it comes to repeating
history's biggest tragedies yeah they
always have the oswald
i'm not saying oswald was innocent um
that's what i always thought he meant by
oh so i'm the patsy
they meant like i'm walking in here
where's the other guys oh it's just me
uh people don't really care about
complicated answers
because it's just easy to blame the one
crazy guy
doing all the talking hatred is like
sports
in movies the public needs a face and a
name and a story
or it doesn't care just like it's easy
to feel bad for one person
whose tragic story you've heard but not
really comprehend ten thousand deaths
with individual stories yeah that was
stalin
yeah one person is a tragedy tragedy one
million
is a stat uh i bet you think
this is a lot in your line of work i bet
you think this a lot in your line of
work a tv show fails and everyone thinks
it's the guy who's on the billboard but
in reality
it's some suit who gave a shitty note
like lean against the wall and smile at
her lovingly
that's the movie poster public the
public wants to see thoughts
thanks for the laughs take care well
i'll get back to that in a second i
gotta make this phone call
hang on hang on it will be half a second
in your life
okay just like that i'm back i am back
what the hell was i talking about
um i don't remember oh the fall guy uh i
bet you see a lot of that in your line
of work a tv show fails
yep i don't see a lot of that i do i
definitely see
uh that's kind of how it works
um you know if you win in football
it's uh you know it's all the
quarterback
you know it's not the offense the
offensive line never gets
credit but they also well i guess they
get blamed if the guy gets sacked a lot
i don't know i understand what you're
saying
um and i do find that uh interesting
and it's also i think it goes back to
this [ __ ] now
where um people want these
uh oh i just learned it what is it these
sjws
come after these cis white males look at
me look at me
i'm saying the things no i think that
it's
it's uh it's about putting a face on it
and more importantly
not their face um
because i think if you're walking around
and you think that you are a woke person
you are not
being honest with yourself basically
saying you don't have any issues with
anybody
and that's [ __ ] and i would tell you
to listen to your inner monologue
especially when you're in situations
where
you feel uh outnumbered and
it's the sun has gone down you listen to
what your inner monologue says to you
and you are not woke
second you get afraid you'd be surprised
what your brain starts thinking so
that's the [ __ ]
you know everybody needs i think
everybody needs to work on themselves
everybody all right and stop with this
[ __ ] [ __ ] of like oh there's the
it's the scarface
you people you need someone like me
there goes the bad guy
um everybody's got a little of that in
him and some people more than others
all right so anyway uh
divorce settlement dear justice burr
recently an athlete celebrity announced
a divorce the celebrity started a
company
while uh recently an athlete and
celebrity announced a divorce
the celebrity started a company while
with the athlete
it is being argued that he deserves half
the cup of the company because
their money that he made was used to
start the business
uh well i mean if i mean that's how
business
works is if somebody like look if
this is how i look at that okay if the
celebrity started the business
oh i see wait but the celebrity had
money anyways oh i get it okay i almost
[ __ ] this up right so if the celebrity
had enough money
to start the company anyway
then yeah this is [ __ ] it is
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's the celebrities business uh seeing
is how in a traditional voice
divorce the wife gets half of what the
man makes even if she didn't partake in
the business
because she provided moral and emotional
support that's a cracker [ __ ]
should a man or woman get half of a
company that they provided
monetary support for
not a loaded question just need a burr
ruling on this thanks and go
find yourself man um
this is what i would argue if that
celebrity
if the person's a celebrity they have
enough money to support themselves
and they have enough money to start a
business
i can tell you this if i was the athlete
i would say listen that's your money
that's your business just let me keep my
sneaker deal money and all of that [ __ ]
all right
and i'll go off and i'll [ __ ] you
know
do whatever the [ __ ] it is i we both
have money let's not be [ __ ] all
right i would just
with them i would just say okay let's
sell the house we'll split that
but i wouldn't personally speaking i
don't think that you should get into
all of you know the celebrities building
a brand and has like a clothing company
or
some [ __ ] [ __ ] like i i don't agree
with that
um but what i will say is at least both
of those people
were working and making money because i
will tell you the moral and emotional
support is the biggest
crock of [ __ ] [ __ ] because there's no
way
to prove that and you could be a total
[ __ ] nag
and also moral and you know i'm sitting
at home i don't have a [ __ ] job
you're going off in a coal mine give
them hell honey
you can do it i play
canary in a coal mine from the police
while uh i make your breakfast in the
morning and then therefore i should have
half your [ __ ] money
i don't agree with it um all right what
i should have said
oh this there's a new segment called
what i should have said everybody
you know those moments in life where you
just let somebody walk all over you
before you even realize it's happening
and then 10 minutes later you think the
thing that you should have said
this is what it is all right donut
dreams hello bill i'm a big fan of yours
and can't wait to see you when you
when you tour through my town this
september i was listening to the may
31st podcast and i have a story about a
time i wish i could go back
and tell this donut baking [ __ ] to to
[ __ ] himself
and that his donuts suck all right here
we go i was with two of my friends and
we were going to our local donut shop
one
late night because we had the munchies
at the time
is was eating a lot of peanut butter
okay at the time i was eating a lot of
peanut butter and jelly sandwiches
because i was broke and they are easy to
make in my altered mood i was curious
what a peanut butter and jelly
donut would taste like so i got all
excited dude how [ __ ] high were you
hey man what if you combined a peanut
butter and jelly sandwich with the
doughnut man
uh so i got all excited yep and you were
one with the world
and you walked in where this sober [ __ ]
was making doughnuts
gee what could go wrong here so i got
excited about the potential of this
store
having a donut with jelly and peanut
butter
we get to the store and i start looking
over the donuts for something that might
have jelly and peanut butter
i see a donut that might have jelly or
something i can't remember exactly what
happened
but ask the baker is that grape jelly
the baker responds grape jelly
what are you pregnant
[Music]
i'm sorry that's [ __ ] hilarious he
goes that's something my pregnant
wife would want he totally shat all over
my donut dream and i didn't know what to
say
i was so high i couldn't think of
anything to say back i probably just
shrugged and gave
i don't know look but we got our donuts
that went on our way
dude what you should have done was you
should have laughed your ass off
and said sorry man i'm high he's not a
[ __ ] dude you were [ __ ] high and that
is a hilarious response
anyways he goes i wish i could have said
something like no i'm not pregnant you
don't it bacon [ __ ] oh don't do that
don't do that you never make fun of what
a person does for a living
uh i learned that the hard way uh i just
want a goddamn donut and peanut butter
and with peanut butter and jelly
i'm not very good at comebacks but i
never bought any more donuts from this
bakery ever again the worst part is the
donuts are actually pretty good
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself all right
this is what you need to do you need to
forgive yourself for being that [ __ ]
high
that you asked for a grape jelly donut
all right yo
have to give that give it up for that
guy that what he said was [ __ ]
hilarious
all right and i think it's time you go
in there and you get you [ __ ] smoke
some weed go in and go have some more
[ __ ] donuts all right
it was funny he just made you feel silly
why did that make you feel so bad you
should have been able to laugh that off
i'm gonna say that maybe were your
parents mean to you growing up
were you bullied a lot is that what it
was because that seems like you brought
a little bit of baggage in there because
that was like
depends on what he said grape jelly what
are you pregnant i would have [ __ ]
fell on the floor laughing
i would have fell on the [ __ ] floor
laughing if the guy said that to me
um you know but at all depends on how we
said it on defense of you
because i remember one time when uh i
didn't know anything about drums
and i was into stuart copeland i wanted
to buy one of those little symbols that
he had i came walking into this music
store
and i was like yeah i want to buy a
symbol do you have like one of those
little symbols you know they're not like
bigger that there's
literally small ones and the guy just
goes you mean a splash
i was just like uh
what you mean a [ __ ] it's just like all
right i'm sorry your band didn't make it
yeah splash sorry this is why you work
here
i'm brand new i'm gonna spend money in
your store you [ __ ]
i get it i know you know did your
friends laugh at you is that what it was
what are you pregnant that's
[ __ ] hilarious um anyway here we go
keep
going moving on here uh what i shouldn't
have said
oh so these turn this person's turning
on the uh
on its ear here what i shouldn't have
said dear billy burberry bat handbag
uh i am the type of person who rarely
says what's on their mind nor do i do
nor do i stand up to passive aggressive
jerks
but one time 20 years ago i lashed out
and said what was on my mind
i was a senior in high school i was in
my senior year of high school and i just
had finished a painting of my girlfriend
jenna i was quite proud of it and was
excited to share it and my next class my
friends asked to see it
i happily passed the painting over to my
peers where people gathered around to
look at it oh god
yep you were too young to know where
this was going to go i took in various
feedback from feigning interest to
genuine compliments oh i thought it was
going to get meaner than that
there was a girl in my school who was a
deeply unkind person
who behaved as if she was god's gift to
men um
when she saw the painting she quipped
that doesn't even look like
jenna in her rude holier-than-thou way
she was known for 99 out of a hundred
times a comment like that would be
internalized and replayed on an
endless self-deprecating cycle oh god
dude
i know i gotta reel the reel machine
with endless tape in my [ __ ] head
uh anyway the person says for some
reason this time i saw
red and without hesitation i angrily
blurted out
no one asked you you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh my god i love that that's [ __ ]
hilarious
she goes the whole class went silent
her face turned beat red
and i was handed back my painting as i
heard someone say jesus christ joey
i cannot say it was my proudest moment
what are you [ __ ] talking about dude
if i was the guy that judged you the
[ __ ] god at the end of my life
you're walking into my waiting room to
see if you're getting to heaven and i'm
doing the dinero come here you
come here you right
he said i cannot say it was my proudest
moment it goes against my desire to be
kind to people hey no no
no no people have to earn if you're a
good person
you have to people have to earn that you
just don't give it to them
uh anyway but it has also become a
guilty pleasure
memory i like to dig up whenever i'm
feeling like a handbag
dude [ __ ] that man
dude you you painted a picture of this
woman you were in love with and she goes
that doesn't even look like jenna okay
no one asked you you [ __ ] [ __ ] like
yeah
i mean that's all aces there's nothing
guilty about that i mean that's that's a
[ __ ]
triumph i mean i i
personally i would watch that clip right
in between
some nfl films about super bowl
victories and
and that at no point would i be like why
was that in there
i would totally see a through line kudos
to you
uh anyway p.s i love your comedy and
think f is for family is a masterpiece
and we'll be forever and will forever be
one of my favorite cartoons thank you
for being you oh that's great thank you
well
you can thank the great mike price
mark wilmore rest his soul david
richardson rest his soul
um emily towers everybody who's written
on that thing
is the reason why it's that great um all
right
wish i said something and after this i'm
gonna have to wrap this [ __ ] up
because i'm gonna be late here
um i wish i said something hey
strawberry short snake
it's some really good ones today
uh you asked for people to write in and
ask the time
they didn't do anything at the time but
wish they had
uh well i was watching a ufc fight with
some friends and we were just drinking
beers cracking joke when a friend of
mine
when a friend of my friend says to me
randomly
you talk a lot of [ __ ] for someone who
has never been in a fight
i looked around to see if anyone heard
what was said and everyone just ignored
it
the guy trains mma and fights locally
and was right
i've never been in a fight but that's
beside the point it was incredibly
[ __ ] rude and it ruined the night i'm
not lying to you when i say
i've hung out with this group hundreds
of times without incident
he's a relatively new friend of a friend
of a friends
i've had for 15 years i said nothing
because i was shocked
i fumed about it for hours and it ruined
my night
i have fantasized about things i should
have said
oh yeah and beating the [ __ ] out of the
guy all that everybody's been this
person
uh i should have said two years later
people act like being the bigger man
is the right thing to do but i don't
know that [ __ ] stays with you
i have let it go and i'm glad i didn't
do anything because i have a kid but
your last podcast reminds me of how
annoying that was
let me know your thoughts uh come back
to new england when you can
um yeah that's a
that's a douchey thing depends on how
bad you would talk if you guys were just
like joking around and [ __ ]
uh you know if he actually trains like
mma
maybe he she should have been the bigger
person i don't know
what can you do the big thing is you got
to like make peace with it
is the real thing yeah it sucks being
called out like that uh
that's more getting called out i feel
you kind of got called out but you're
man enough to say he was right
so i don't think you're a bad person and
uh i don't know
i mean what were you gonna do throw a
punch at the guy and then get your ass
kicked but then he'd respect you
uh part of watching mma is to be [ __ ]
laughing and
oh you i mean that's one thing i don't
like about commenters on those mma
things
you know you got knocked the [ __ ] out
and all of that type of [ __ ]
and i i just never felt uh
i don't know but i guess i do that with
hockey though i'll talk about people
that could beat the [ __ ] out of me
saying that they were
cheap pieces of [ __ ] so i guess we all
do it
yeah that sucks
it sucks you know none of your friends
said anything like hey man take it easy
we're just [ __ ] around having fun he
knows he can't beat up these guys
relax all right there bruce lee hey if
you were any better wouldn't you be on
the [ __ ] we'd be watching you right
now
all right there's strip mall fighter um
and then he kicks the [ __ ] out of
everybody in the room
um all right underrated living in the
past i have no problem with people who
want to watch
me tv and dream about a different time i
think it's healthy and can help you
happier in the present i revisit old tv
and music all the time and think about
summers of old it makes me happy and i
haven't completely lost touch with
my life bills are paid and the family is
happy
yeah i kind of agree with you i uh am
going back just watching all these
movies that i either saw when i was a
kid or never saw
and i just there's so many little
[ __ ] things in there that make me
smile
literally like they'll be in a diner
and you just see like glasses instead of
those plastic [ __ ] things
a a napkin dispenser a kid
rides up on a bike a bike you haven't
seen
you know since you were a kid where a
kid you know in uh
one of those dirty harry's these guys
going to rob a liquor store first of all
that there's a kid in the liquor store
in the movie which they would never do
in today's movies because what kind of
message would that send
and the kid goes to run out of the store
when they take out their guns and this
guy
grabs the kid and throws him in into a
display
and what i loved about it was he was
wearing a numbered shirt
in the 70s kids used to wear numbered
shirts
they had nothing to do they had no
sports affiliation to them they just
were a numbered shirt
and when i saw that that just you know
it made me smile and also seen an adult
throwing a kid that wasn't his
into a display in a store and nobody
doing anything about it
regardless of the fact that they had
guns just made me [ __ ] laugh my ass
off so uh i 100
agree with that um all right that is the
podcast
uh go [ __ ] yourselves and i'll check in
on you
on thursday